you found that the men in your life are
literally
um all more logical than you and is that
is that a lack of turn on for you or a
turn off turn on
I enjoy time
no so can we get one yeah yeah oh I
wanted yeah
I think it teaches me something so oh
wow like I didn't have to
make everything so big so you can just
sit down and solutionize and I like the
fact that I can find Solutions and I
enjoy being around masculine energy that
teach me how to just like you know work
things out so yeah that's my answer
um it's a turn on now but at a point in
time it wasn't because I wasn't
I wasn't ready to hear the logic I
wanted to be babied right
um and obviously that also comes from
like upbringing and like how your
parents treat and deliver you so yeah
okay so yeah but now yeah I've always
been quite lucky in that sense I've
always had like relationships where the
Mal's kind of been like the mountain
it's just like still and calm and I've
always been quite good at like
reflecting on when like the energy
emotion inside me is wearing up as to
like understand that I'm being triggered
by something right and to have that
space held for me without it me being
like it's you me being like I know that
I'm in a tizz right now can you just
like
chill a second and like just hold the
space so yeah I'm quite and yeah it's
definitely attractive when you know that
you're like being held okay
[Music]
oh yeah I love logic
it's actually it's actually a Pity that
you don't display any but you know you
love you love a logical man yeah I do
it's just easier I just like things that
it's like one plus one equals two that's
it
okay this is she won the mathematician I
am quite the mathematician actually I'll
tell you that
logic works for me yeah he's worn me
down he's turned him into his perfect
woman I've always been logical because I
was a tomboy but
I think according to him
he's making sure I've Got the Right Mix
of femininity and logical and get rid of
the emotional [ __ ]
so if I feel emotional I was just
getting I can't find a Motorway
I'm gonna get rid of that emotion no I
think
no I think after 32 years
otherwise you're gonna are you gonna
converse with I mean I feel like you
have an emotional reaction initially
like especially as someone who's in
literally the most logical like part of
YouTube you know yeah but like you have
an emotional reaction initially but it's
kind of like guys around you can train
you to like look at things a different
way and know when you read like when you
have that like gut reaction to like wait
wait or you know um like for for example
um like the two-day thing I think that's
been really helpful in my life or even
when I'm in a heated debate like my mom
would always tell me like the person
that gets emotional first they lose so
stay stay very calm and don't don't
raise your voice like just stay stay
cool as a cute it is stuff like that
where like they kind of train you a
little bit I think women try to trigger
an emotional many women try to trigger
an emotional reaction out of a man and
you know what I really like the fact
that WhatsApp you can delete the
messages from everyone
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I'm not texting angry again yeah that
angry text is like funny those angry
texts are trying to draw men into your
to women's like and I realized that
that's why I have to stop myself you
know what's crazy you realize you don't
want a solution because that's kind of
one thing my dad whenever I get really
frustrated about something most of the
time with my dad it's actually about
like work stuff but he he's like why are
you getting mad like what's the solution
like you can't get mad at the problem
like you have to think about the
solution so like if you're thinking like
he does that that and that you do blah
blah blah like you're not you're not
telling him what the solution is and
it's really hard because you're just
like mad but for me that's always helped
me just be like very solution minded and
men are always going to look for a
solution that's why when women come home
from work and be like oh my God this
happened at work and so-and-so did this
and and man will sit there listen like
[Music]
does at any point men enjoy the slight
like emotional or sensitivity that women
come with I think I think men enjoy
being able
to be the solution for their woman okay
Mama finds it funny yeah like I think I
think it's quite enjoyable
they find it funny
There She Goes Again he's like yeah
she's all and sometimes it's not me
because there's some weird women out
there that keep away from my man but
there's some weird women out there that
will send texts you know who you are but
you're following me I don't care whether
you're following it you're not my friend
so don't be subscribing to me because
like you're cooking my mental of rice
anyway so remember to see all this kind
of stuff right and they will look at it
and they would think like yeah right
that's funny because that's emotional
say look at you like
they show me he shows me the Sexes no
yeah look at that
especially to answer to that yeah and
it's funny because we
were some kind of emotional Summit to
try and draw the men in because they
want a reaction especially if they think
that men's logic there's something they
say is being hot-headed so they're like
I'm gonna push this button then maybe he
would do this and you'll find that
they'll send one text it don't work
they'll send another text yeah yeah then
it's in a voicemail and it don't work
then they want to call you if he doesn't
answer the phone don't call back you
call you no don't work and then you find
that the women exhausted themselves and
the man's just sitting there like so
funny billboard a comedian billboard The
Comedian says that he's learned in the
way in which women argue and he said if
if if if you beat a woman via logic in
an argument what she's doing he said
that she's concocting right this Hail
Mary argument to just throw at you just
to get you to like react
so you can just call her a [ __ ] elephant
and then once you do that like once you
call her that or you do that thing she's
like she's well oh my God
and then it's like you've lost because
now you've like you've you've bought
into her you can't you can't fight in
the same battle yeah you can't fight
because you will lose every time
into it too it makes us more emotional
than if like I feel like we kind of
almost mirror the guys a little bit or
if the guy's really calm it kind of
forces you to stay a little bit calmer
yeah yeah I prefer that yeah me too you
can't remember otherwise you can go
crazy and I'll be real
updated women and I feel like I learned
a lot about myself when there's a
certain routine and I know that that
message is coming and you're going to
send that message again then you're
going to disappear for an hour and let
nothing happen it's really not cool it's
not cool and it made me look at myself
in a way like why did I ever do that
because I know I'm reading the message
that I'm not even replying to it maybe
this is the cure no I think we need all
women to just take it away
did dating women make you appreciate man
yeah well yeah but well when I went to
Africa did yeah
[Music]
absolutely rooting for them
it's different and I was dating women
for a long like four or five oh my gosh
don't worry for a while yeah and then I
went to Ghana and I was like oh
you're so strong the men are men you
want to hold my bag yeah oh I like this
you know what I mean so yeah but yeah
well it's so funny on a different note I
find that mentality amazing that you
could switch
now men if a man has I'm gonna I dated a
guy for four years
two women I'm cool I have a question did
you did you start dating women after
like a toxic relationship with a guy
oh never really thought about it and how
old were you when you started and
stopped dating women
oh stop oh gosh we haven't stopped we
didn't stop we're just just okay
um but yeah um
age 20 about 20 it's not about 24. okay
and yeah until 29 was when you speaking
yeah okay can I ask a question and was
it afternoon relationships
I was quite I was talking to your mate
oh sorry I was about yeah 16 when I went
into my first relationship and it lasted
a very long period of time I was
intermitting me and the guy were in
church together and I kind of felt like
[Laughter]
I found that like when girls start
dating girls it's usually after a toxic
relationship and they either start or
stop around 28 to like
31.50 yeah
so stop because like typically a lot of
times they may want like the family unit
and so then they'll go back or they kind
of age out of the this is just
observations in my opinion
um they age out of the dating Market
with like men and so then they start to
date women because they can't get the
men they want anymore interesting
um they always thought to myself that
women sometimes they're in toxic
relationships or they have been and they
just need time out of a woman
just to feel like a woman again
it's like after a toxic relationship
they like don't even want to be the man
they're like yeah like go to a woman and
the second is like I feel like it's
usually they can't get the like compete
for the men they want anymore yeah and
like they always say like girls would
rather be with a woman than settle for a
beta and so sometimes the women are more
pushed too I could be as I can men can
be sick of women they could be like oh
my God I'm never gonna go and get a man
are you crazy
it's different it's all about
penetration that's why it's different
well I think I think there's like a I
don't know
penetration women um they did a study
where women like to see when what women
were aroused by and they found that like
women cap a lot about what they're
aroused by like they would say or you
roused by this image that image that
image and they would say no no no and I
don't remember and like then they would
see I don't know maybe I don't know how
they measured it but there's some way
you can like tell right and like a lie
detector type thing no it wasn't a lie
detector like I think when you're
aroused like your heart rate go
something I don't know what medically it
was I just know they measure it or like
something in your brain lights up or
something and I remember like women
capped a lot about not be like about
being attracted to other women or like
the majority of women actually were
attracted to other women oh yeah yeah
that's very attractive but sometimes
the way you've grown up but also also
remember women find 80 of men
unattractive so like women again I think
like if women can't get a certain
percentage of men like this okay they'd
rather date a woman I think women are
more comfortable to practice intimacy
within the agenda as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible